عمره من عمر النكبه
هو مخيم برج البراجنه للاجئين الفلسطينيين
مساحته الصغيره تفيد بهموم ساكنيه ولا
تتسع لاحلامهم في واحد من اشد مخيمات
لبنان اقتظاظا قصص الحرمان وضيق الحال هي
القوت اليومي لساكنيه
القانون اللبناني الذي يحرمه كف فلسطيني
من ممارسه عشرات الوظائف من بينها قياده
سياره اجره مجازفه لم تعد تعود عليه الا
بالقليل
احنا ماما سموحنا
مخاطره يعني هو حسب ضميره الدراجه انا معي
ما معي دكتور عمومي انا ممنوع اشتغل على
التاكسي
الامام مسموح لنا يعني
لازم اشتغل
لازم اشتغل واعيش عندي اولاد
اجتماعيا اوضاع زادها سوءا الانهيار
الاقتصادي في لبنان
العوده
معاناتهم في مخيمات الشتات تتكسف مع لممها
الفلسطيني
فساده مين الالامهم الانهيار الاقتصادي
وضعف تمويل الاونروا الا ان الواقع
المعيشي المترديه للاجئين الفلسطينيين هنا
ليقتصر على شده الاقتضاض ومعدلات البطاله
المرتفعه بل يتجاوزها الى الحاجه الماسه
للعلاج في مستوصف الاونروا يحضر اللاجئون
برعايه الاوليه اما علاج الحالات الاكثر
تعقيدا فتغطيه المنظمه الدوليه بنسب
متفاوته
نحن بشكل جزئي واللاج الفلسطيني غير قادر
على دفع الفرق نفس الشيء بالنسبه للادويه
لبعض الامراض او الحالات الصعبه
سلامه هل عاوز كل شيء وبعد اصابتها بالفشل
الكلوي باتت جمانه في سعي يومي لتامين
الدواء وسباق مع الزمن لتجميع اربعه الاف
دولار تعينها على اجراء عمليه جراحيه
كمان كثير صعبه ما قادره اعمل له شيء بقول
لهم في شيء ابدا
صاحبي بدي اقدر اوقف هدوم اطفال
تتخلص خيارات اللاجئين الفلسطينيين فمنهم
من يتعايش مرغما مع واقعه القاهر ومنهم من
يختار الهجره او حتى ركوب قوارب الموت اما
الجامع بينهم فهو حلم العوده كارمن جخدر
الجزيره من مخيم برج البراجنه للاجئين
الفلسطينيين